bonjour à vous tous bonjour hizbut si
notre invité ce matin et laurent vidal
bonjour bonjour merci d'être dans ce
studio vous êtes enseignant chercheur à
l'université de la rochelle
vous vous intéressez particulièrement
parmi vos travaux circulation des
personnes et des idées dans l'espace
atlantique alors laurent vidal
vous êtes en martinique depuis plusieurs
jours à l'invitation de l'association
karisko vous avez d'ailleurs participé à
la dernière grande manifestation de
caris co ici le grand week où vous allez
nous en dire quelques mots on rappelle
simplement que l'association karisko
valorise le patrimoine hérité des
amérindiens dans la zone caraïbes prise
dans son sens le plus large c'est en
tout cas
l'action principale de caris co op pas
que ça mais voilà et donc voilà caris co
qui vise à créer et à faciliter les
conditions d'une appropriation par les
martiniquais d'une filiation à
l'histoire amérindienne de ce pays
laurent vidal comment s'est passé
comment se passe votre séjour ici est il
intéressant et en quoi vous est-il
enrichissant écoutez déjà merci pour
cette pour cette invitation
c'est instinct séjour merveilleux
merveilleux par les rencontres notamment
les rencontres que karisko permet à
l'occasion entre autres de ceux de ce
grand week où la thématique de ce grand
week ou était sur les créations des
caribéens c'est à dire que là on n'est
pas uniquement n'était pas uniquement
rester sur la question amérindienne
l'idée des caraïbes prise un peu au sens
également je dirais symbolique comme
espace de rencontre entre alors en
rencontres volontaire involontaire force
et non forcé voulu non voulue mais on
essaie de dépasser le contexte même pour
voir ce que cela a donné
et en quoi ces créations partie de deux
de ses espaces relativement restreint
ont pu transformer voire révolutionner
parfois le monde notre paysage sonore
notre paysage
et notre imaginaire et c'est donc et là
évidemment
moi qui ne suis pas un grand habitué
disons de la martinique ce n'est que la
deuxième fois que je viens
mais en revanche un habitué j'irai de
l'atlantique je retrouve ici des
éléments qui entrent en dialogue avec
ayant résonance avec ce qui est mon
univers alors on va revenir un peu sur
ce que ça induit un ce travail justement
autour des créations des caribéens que
veut aussi valoriser karisko les
revenants sur ce com comment s'est
déroulée finalement cette réunion se ce
week ou et puis et puis on en viendra
avec cette collaboration parce que bon
vous êtes là pour respirer le bon air de
la martinique que pour avoir des moments
de détente mais aussi donc vous l'avez
expliqué pour travailler en tant que
ubuntu on va y revenir au bout tout pour
l'association karisko mai mais bon voilà
le week où je vous demandais alors le
week où était et est donc c'est une une
fin d'après-midi et une longue soirée
qui s'est passé en différents moments il
ya eu d'abord une sorte bon d'abord
l'accueil des invités ça ce tome on
manque solennel est assez important il y
a eu également des mises en scène de
type avec des petites scènes théâtrales
sur justement les les grands héros des
caraïbes des héros amérindiens des héros
noirs des héros des pirates etc
et c'est donc tout un ensemble de
petites saynètes qui ont été jouées par
des membres de caris co et qui sont
absolument fabuleuse
il y a eu également
une dirait en direct on a assisté à une
création d'un tableau par un groupe où
il y à un peintre un slameur des
musiciens se pince s'appelle christophe
mer et ça c'était était véritablement
géré en direct nous avons assisté à
cette cette création
et puis ce fameux cercle sacré qui est
un instant extrêmement solennelle dans
le grand week ou où chaque membre du
cercle sacré et bien s'engage pour
l'année à venir ou disons dans le cadre
de la thématique du morne cette année
puisqu'il s'agissait du monde création
des quarts et bien et bien s'engage sur
un certain nombre de promesses d'actions
qu'il va réaliser
est ce que vous avez fait vous donc
laurent vidal historien qui allaient qui
donc travaillent travail vous collaborez
avec karisko donc vous êtes engagés pour
exactement
alors je me suis engagé sur sur sur un
engagement qui peut paraître un petit
peu étonnant comme ça mais qui quand
j'ai réfléchi me paraît de plus en plus
essentiel dans l'autre monde de
réapprendre de réapprendre à
m'émerveiller et et et au delà de ça je
crois que les enfants cette capacité
d'émerveillement
c'est à dire d'interroger le monde les
choses mais pourquoi c'est comme ça
pourquoi c'est les enfants qui posent
des questions et nous avons tellement
l'habitude de ne plus poser de question
qu'on considère les choses comme acquise
et réapprendre à s'émerveiller c'est
réapprendre à porter un regard nouveau
sur le monde qui nous entoure et ce
monde car il création des caribéens va
s'appuyer
j'irai sur cette capacité
d'émerveillement que l'on doit récupérer
cette capacité à regarder les choses
sous une lumière de louvain
la voilà alors on le précise donc le
grand louis kulubu tout ça ce sont des
termes à meyrin des amérindiens voilà
notamment signé donc grands week ou
grandes manifestations grande fête
grande célébration voilà et aux buttes
ou alors vous êtes lubutu de
l'association karisko alors ça peut se
traduire enfin où on peut on peut
l'expliquer par différentes manières bon
le membre d'honneur chevilles ouvrières
capitaine de bateau comme disait marcel
rapon le prêt des installations karisko
tout à l'heure puisqu'il n'est pas loin
de ce studio il vous a accompagnés donc
voilà alors vous êtes le goût pour ce
projet morne des créations des caribéens
alors expliquez nous qu'est-ce que ça
regroupe sept de mordre des créations
des caribéens
là on est autour des créations
caribéenne ici ou là dans l'espace
atlantique dans différentes zones
géographiques de l'atlantique on va dire
mais qui c'est un peu le même le même
processus de métissage de syncrétisme de
finalement de deux rencontres des
échanges culturels internationaux entre
différentes cultures différentes peuple
c'est ça écoutez il ya il ya 2 il ya
deux idées qui seront à la base il ya
peut-être un verre je sais qu'ici on
cite beaucoup aimé césaire je ne
voudrais pas tomber mais mais malgré
tout c'est des verts qui sont absolument
fabuleux ceux qui n'ont inventé ni la
poudre ni la boussole
ceux qui n'ont jamais su dompter
le l'électricité ni la vapeur ni
l'électricité mais ceux sans qui le
monde ne serait pas le monde alors ça
c'est le point de départ de dire on va
travailler sur les créations pas sur les
inventions les inventions ça suppose un
processus intellectuel c'est la création
elle peut être inattendu elle n'est de 7
des rencontres donc on va travailler la
génération d émergence et c'est à partir
de là que on peut en arriver à cette
autre idée qu'il y à il y a certes des
caraïbes géographiquement au des limites
et qui sont connus mais si on veut bien
considérer que les caraïbes
sur le plan symbolique c'est un espace
de rencontre inopinée entre des cultures
différentes
et bien il y à d'autres caraïbes au
moins dans l'atlantique pour qui est un
espace que je connais je pense aux îles
du cap vert je pense à des ports
brésiliens que je connais bien qu'il
s'agit de salvador de rioz mais je pense
à un port que je connais aussi au maroc
qui s'appelle essaouira et on va essayer
là dedans ces lieux que vous venez de
citer il ya des processus de dépôt de
civilisation de créolisation et moi ce
qui m'intéresse ce qui m'intéresse et
autour de la musique c'est pour ça qu'on
veut lancer une grande île grande un
grand projet musical un concert ici où
il y aurait des musiques à la fois du
cap vert à la fois ici de bien sûr ici
en martinique
l'enjeu ça serait de faire ça au mois de
novembre donc on a dans ce projet
création en mode création des caribéens
dirait trois projets si je peux me
permettre à l'ue de lait oui vous avez
encore une minute
alors voilà donc ce projet musical qui
permettra de montrer ses hôtes caraïbes
et montrer ce qui se passe ici de les
faire se créer un dialogue mais il ya
aussi un projet qui est directement
gérée liées qui va se mettre en place au
début à la martinique ce que j'ai appelé
un cahier des merveilles déposés dans
les écoles primaires des cahiers
physique pour que les gens que les
enfants appellent leurs familles que les
parents les grands parents viennent
écrire une recette de cuisine viennent
expliquer l'usagé d'une plante
vienne dessinée viennent déposer une
photographie et ça on va lancer à partir
des journées du patrimoine
ces cahiers des merveilles et on veut
aussi à côté
comme je disais il s'agit de développer
un regard neuf lancé un concours de
photographies et de vidéos autour des
créations des caribéens
tout ça sera lancée autour des journées
du patrimoine
et il y aura un prix également qui sera
remis avec une diffusion sur le site de
caris co voilà un petit peu les trois
actions concert cahier des merveilles
concours de photographie voilà et donc
vous vous intervenez en tant que nous
tous alors voilà conseiller scientifique
ou simplement partenaires de de caris co
pour donc faire tout ça dans les
semaines les mois qui viennent ou
rêveurs comme des marcels répond et
comme dit caris co puisque l'enjeu de
caris co c'est ça à chacun son rêve donc
tellement bon travail
mon travail est bonne réalisation de
rêves laurent vidal
merci l'association karisko bonne
journée et bon week-end à vous tous